قال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
ماثيو ميلر ان تحميل الولايات المتحده او
اسرائيل مسؤوليه تفجيري ايران امر سخيف
واضاف ميلر في مؤتمر صحفي ان الولايات
المتحده ليست متورطه باي شكل من الاشكال
وليس لديها سبب للاعتقاد بان اسرائيل
متورطه في انفجارات في
ايران فيما يتعلق بالتفجير في ايران اليوم
اود ان اقول اننا نتابع الانباء من كثب
وليس لدينا اي معلومات مستقله بشانه ما
نعرب عن تعاطفنا مع الضحايا واقربائهم
الذين لقوا حتفهم في هذا الانفجار المروع
وكما قلت من السابق لاوانه على الاقل
بالنسبه الينا ان نحدد السبب الذي قد يكون
وراء ذلك الولايات المتحده ليست ضالع باي
شكل من الاشكال واي اقتراح بعكس ذلك هو
امر مثير للص قريه وثانيا ليس لدينا اي
سبب للاعتقاد بان اسرائيل ضعه في هذا
الانفجار